hi there and welcome back to the future
of documents I'm Holt Skinner and I'm a
developer advocate for Google Cloud
previously we looked at document AI
specialized processors and how they can
provide intelligent insights into
certain document types by providing
consistent schemas and normalizing data
to reduce the amount of pre and post
processing you need to perform
however Google's pre-trained models only
cover a finite set of document types
what if you have a unique type of
document and want to get the same
detailed information or you're not
getting the accuracy you need from a
pre-trained processor
well this is where document AI workbench
comes in document AG workbench covers
customized processors which is one of
the key building blocks of document AI
processors
[Music]
document AI offers the ability to
uptrain existing processors or create
new processors completely from scratch
to get the most accurate information
from any document type
the good news is you don't have to be a
data scientist or ml specialist to make
models rather you can create or uptrain
models right from the Google Cloud
console this works very similarly to
automl with vertex AI
let's start with up training so suppose
you have a document format that's very
similar to one that has a pre-trained
processor but just doesn't work the way
you want out of the box maybe it has
custom Fields aren't detected by the
pre-trained processors or the processor
output just isn't as accurate as you'd
like
up training a processor allows you to
create your own versions of processors
that are based on pre-trained processors
you can extend the existing schema to
extract new fields or you can create a
processor to read a new document type
that has a lot in common with an
existing processor
this reduces the training and
development time required because the
model has already been trained on lots
of documents custom processors can be
used when you have a type of document
that isn't similar to any existing
processors you can create a new
processor from scratch that allows you
to extract entities using your own
document types let's look at some
examples first we'll look at an invoice
from a fictional veterinary office
the invoice parser can extract standard
invoice Fields like invoice number
supplier name and due date however this
invoice also contains the pet's name
which we also need to extract and the
invoice parser doesn't recognize this
field out of the box
this would be a case to use up training
because it includes many fields that are
common for invoices
so we can add pet name to the schema and
train a new processor version that can
be extra specialized for this document
structure
here's what a partial output could look
like for our uptrained invoice processor
the output includes existing Fields such
as supplier name and receiver name and
also includes our custom pet name fields
next let's look at this patent record
from the US patent and trademark office
these documents follow a consistent
structure but there isn't a pre-trained
parser that works well with them we can
create a custom document extractor to
recognize and extract the fields in
these records using a custom defined
entity schema based on the outputs that
we're interested in
here's what the annotations and output
could look like
creating custom and uptrained processors
follow the same basic steps let's go
through the workflow in the cloud
console
here's how you can get started with an
entity extraction processor be sure to
check out the code labs and
documentation in the description for
more details
first you create a new processor this
works the same as any other processor
you'd want to use select custom document
extractor to create a brand new
processor or select a specialized
processor type to use uptraining then
you import examples of the documents
you'd like to parse we are creating a
customized machine learning model so we
need to provide document AI with
detailed and labeled examples to teach
it how we want this type of document to
be understood
next we Define the document schema using
labels for each entity we want to
extract
then we use the labeling tools to select
the parts of the document we want to
associate with each label and continue
labeling documents until we have enough
examples for our ground truth training
and test data sets the training data
will be used to define the model that
will be used for processing and the test
data we use to evaluate how well the
processor reforms
next we can start training a new version
this will take some time but up training
can be faster because we're building on
top of a pre-trained model
after training is done we can evaluate
the model using our test set of labeled
documents to determine how often each
entity is extracted correctly the
evaluation tool uses standard metrics
such as Precision recall and F1 score to
determine the accuracy of the trained
model
the evaluation looks good the new
processor version is ready to be
deployed and used for predictions each
version can be managed and used to
processing independently
after the processor version is deployed
we can use it exactly the same way as
any other specialized processor we can
make batch or online processing calls
extract entities and send documents for
human review keep in mind you can always
add more labeled documents for training
and testing and create new versions over
time to get the best results
after you've created the first version
of your processor you can enable auto
labeling which will use earlier versions
to label the entities for you you'll
just have to verify and approve the
labels to use them for training and
testing today we've looked at document
AI workbench one of the newest features
of document AI which allows you to
create custom processors and uptrain
existing specialized processors now it's
your turn to use document AI workbench
check out the uptraining and custom
processors quick starts Linked In the
description for step-by-step guides on
how to use these features and be sure to
check out the cloud documentation for
the latest information thank you so much
for watching don't forget to like
comment and subscribe
[Music]
foreign
[Music]